but right now our main responsibility is
to not [ __ ] the people who are actually
fighting this thing right that's our
main responsibility that's why I'm kind
of just like look dude if I have to sit
on my ass and lose my mind for a couple
months that's that that's that's a small
price to pay for making sure that I
don't [ __ ] the others in the front line
so can I ask you sweetie because
remember everyone in my family is a
front liners I know they are and yeah
and kalila she has I haven't seen my
brother Steve at all and my brother's
called me and go take we can't hang out
I go know when when kalila sister comes
over to we exchange things they don't
come in the house we look we talk to
them when we're on the balcony and
they're on the driveway and it's really
sad but we're doing our part in terms of
that but I want to ask kalila so is
there no circumstances where we can get
any kind of delivery what kind of
delivery like from Terry's okay here's
my argument is that if we continue to
use instacart or to get a food runner I
still feel really terrible that I am
putting those people at risk those
people at risk you know they're not well
taken care of
for starters like instacart or Whole
Foods they're not taking care of their
employees their Health's are at risk
they still have to go home to families
so my thing is like I want to minimize
having someone even though they I know
it it it keeps them afloat they want
it's not their people I know but there
are people out there that want to make
money
I understand they want and they they
need food they want to run the food but
they're that money won't make any sense
if there is no life to live in six
months is that so you're basically
saying you're saying no
Terry's no like I'm I have just one bean
cheese and rice burrito I mean I just
don't have a
for us in a lot of things right now Jose
remember nachos I you seem to think
you're the only one that wants those
things I know I'm just cuz I just I mean
I'm just bringing up for humor can I do
it one thing that I ain't but I bet your
money though terry bummed about there
probably there right now going you know
but you know can I do something really
sad I had a door - person come and they
had the no-contact delivery know that
whole thing where you have to they have
to leave the food and they have to walk
away and then you can open door she this
woman was walking with her little
daughter and I made me so sad cuz you're
like she wouldn't take her kid out there
she didn't have to but it was like she
just is all she's thinking about his
money clearly which is like do you not
take your kid outside but it's like I'm
I don't know her situation but it's like
but I'm not in my own life at least and
the things that I can control whether
it's my you know whether it's our
gardener or somebody who works for us
even if it's like a dog sitter we give
them money and say hey it is just even
if they haven't done any service I don't
want them to do any service like
whatever I can do to give money to those
people who say hey stay home and even
that's like that is the card lady or
that Runner if I had seen her I would
have said okay here's a certain amount
of money if you can if that helps you
not have to do as many runs you know and
I think that people with money should
step up in that way and and I don't
understand like truly like we are around
a lot of rich people man like you guys
are we live in LA like we can do our
part in that way when I okay so i've had
two deliveries from 7-eleven because I
need Diet Coke so bad right and
obviously we're you know we we wear the
mask it gets dropped off we wipe it down
and all that stuff but you know I always
leave like a huge you know tip so can we
do this with Terry's just to hear me out
right we order from Terry's but we don't
ask we don't actually get a deliver
we'll just order it and tell the person
in the message
you know we don't actually you can eat
the food yeah just the idea of ordering
Terry's will make me feel better imagine
in my mind that it's coming in you order
Terry's right you're not jealous
and they kalila you make the food leave
it outside the door see feels like he's
getting delivery so everyone wins yeah
yeah I don't know why but I just crave
nachos right nacho that's such a lie
I'll tell you what I crave I just said
do this mine's Korean barbecue I met
some sort of Mexican right I crave East
Coast food I know yeah so Jersey Mike's
like crave it I crave a little bit you
know what else I crave Panda Express for
some reason mmm you know I miss Asian
food yeah like I miss like Newports
seafood whoo-hoo I'll tell you what I've
been playing though can we talk about
what I've been doing with my days oh
yeah I'm a gamer now apparently what do
you what are you playing I'm playing the
widest game ever a war zone call duty is
it good it's fun when you're playing
with people you're talking you're
laughing it's fun I get the whole
destiny thing now I get it you do I
guess yeah it's fun it's fine but all
because I don't want to do that because
I want to scream and I want to get all
stressed out yeah so and what do you
think I've been so so what I do is I go
all right I'm gonna go down for an hour
but I spent six hours right never see
him I mean you never see so we really
have been playing down there babe I
think that you initially no no there's
this it's not it's